et vous feriez erreur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
si vous considériez que le texte que le
gouvernement vous présente affaibli le
sénat car vous le savez et vous le savez
parfaitement ce texte sera adopté en
dernière lecture par l'assemblée
nationale avec les principes et les
équilibres qui vous ont été données et
c'est pour ça que vous devez accompagner
ce texte
quel que soit le vote tu seras le vôtre
ce texte sera adopté et le renforce le
sénat le cumul des mandats les jeux sont
faits avant même la discussion au sénat
le message délivré par le ministre de
l'intérieur dans son discours
d'introduction est limpide
peu importe que le sénat adoptera à
mandera ou votera c'est plié
la bataille est perdue d'avancé
la limitation du cumul des mandats
éternel serpent de mer
françois hollande en fait une promesse
de campagne symbole d'une rénovation
politique le candidat hollande surf
ainsi sur une mesure populaire l'opinion
publique est majoritairement favorable
au non-cumul
c'est pourquoi je ferai voter dès le
début du prochain quinquennat
la fin du cumul d'un mandat
parlementaire avec une fonction
d'exécutif local
cette promesse de campagne porte la
patte de martine aubry alors première
secrétaire du parti socialiste la maire
de lille présente le non cumul des
mandats comme le gage d'une démocratie
plus moderne
déjà en mai 2010 et malgré l'hostilité
d'une majorité des sénateurs socialistes
elle vient plaider sa cause des mots
prophétiques cette position du non cumul
est pour moi un élément majeur de la
rénovation et de l'image que donne notre
parti et que je suis convaincu que aux
sénatoriales comme aux présidentielles
c'est un parti ouvert capable de se
renouveler
faisons rentrer des jeunes des femmes
des hommes et des femmes de la diversité
qui aura encore plus de crédibilité
auprès des français merci
bon c'était bien parce que
mais trois ans après ces mots le malaise
est toujours présent malgré l'insistance
du gouvernement
la haute assemblée à la veille de
l'examen du projet de loi n'est toujours
pas rentré dans le rang et si ici le
président du groupe socialiste françois
rebsamen pose aux côtés du premier
ministre
il incarne pourtant l'opposition du
sénat au texte du gouvernement
l'ami du président est devenu frondeur
dans ma conviction pour l'intérêt de la
qualité de la loi des législateurs c'est
qu'il est important que les sénateurs
puissent conserver avant d'un exécutif
local au palais du luxembourg le front
anti cumul transcende les clivages
politiques
il se compose d'une partie des sénateurs
socialistes de l'ump du groupe centriste
et du rds or le rds eux le rassemblement
démocratique social et européen
principalement des radicaux de gauche
est un allié indispensable de la
majorité socialiste
mais sur ce texte la résistance est
totale cette loi sur le non-cumul en
fait c'est un cache sexe d'une opération
qui va mutilé une partie de notre
démocratie territoriale nos démocraties
représentatives en général face à eux
communistes écologistes et une partie
des socialistes
il souhaite avec cette réforme donner
une autre image du sénat plus moderne
si des élus des sénatrices et
dessinateur de la majorité parlementaire
ne souhaite pas ce texte dont il sera
retoqué on va renvoyer justement aux
citoyennes et aux citoyens le fait qu'on
s'occupe de nos petites affaires entre
nous et qu'on leur demande pas leur avis
est que ce texte sera sans doute
retoquée minfin et il sera adopté par
l'assemblée nationale ce qui tend aussi
à montrer que aujourd'hui les sénatrices
et les sénateurs en tout cas le
le sénat sa parole mais ne pointe pas en
juillet c'est simon sutour qui est nommé
rapporteur du texte
un rapporteur qu'on envoie au casse-pipe
je pense qu'on nous agissons pour une
bonne cause que c'est un bon projet de
loi doit aussi à nous convaincre mes
collègues qu'il faut l'adopter mais il
peut compter sur le soutien sans faille
du président de la commission des lois
jean pierre sueur positif
les deux sénateurs chevalier blanc du
non cumul et en juillet 2013 voilà le
gouvernement rassurer l'assemblée
nationale chambre plus docile adopte le
projet de loi à la majorité absolue
conséquence même avec un vote négatif du
sénat cette loi organique devrait être
entériné le texte adopté par l'assemblée
nationale et qui arrive au sénat
interdit le cumul entre un mandat
parlementaire et un mandat exécutif
local
un sénateur ou un député ne pourra plus
être maire ni président de conseil
général ou régional
à condition de laisser passer les
prochains rendez vous électoraux
vous le savez la date d'application du
principe de non cumul a fait débat je me
suis impliqué personnellement c'était
mon rôle
lors des travaux préparatoires pour une
application en 2017
après le renouvellement général de
chacune des deux assemblées
cette solution permet à chacune et à
chacun de s'organiser de prévoir de
garder sa liberté de choix
si les électeurs évidemment le veulent
bien parce que en définitive ce sont eux
qui décident
cette solution après de loi précédente
en 1985 et 2000 c'est donc une nouvelle
étape pour le non cumul des mandats mais
il sera toutefois toujours possible pour
un sénateur ou un député de rester et le
local la réforme en cours n'empêcherait
pas c'était adopté un député ou un
sénateur de conserver un mandat local
les députés comme les sénateurs pourront
rester conseiller municipal conseiller
départemental conseiller régional et il
ne me semble pas qu'il faille
nécessairement détenir un mandat
exécutif local pour être un élu local
la loi fait l'impasse sur la limitation
des cumuls dans le temps de même pas un
mot sur le cumul dix horizontale un même
élu pourra donc encore cumuler la mairie
la communauté d'agglomération les
communautés urbaines l'intercommunalité
et bientôt les métropoles
des oublis condamné par de nombreux
sénateurs
bon je pense qu il est totalement
anormal et que d'ailleurs il ya un
conflit d'intérêts importants entre des
lui qui est maire d'une grande ville par
exemple et qui va vérifier la métropole
où la communauté urbaine ça me paraît
absolument impensable donc ça existe cas
sont nombreux et notamment à gauche y
compris à gauche voilà donc safari du
édenté on sait très bien que en plus
quand on est maire et président de
communauté d'agglo au président en plus
toute une série d'organismes qui font
que il ya un vrai cumul horizontal qui
s'est développée particulier avec la
décentralisation et qu'on ne peut pas
traiter du cumul verticale centre est et
du cumul horizontale cumulé une pratique
très française dans nos assemblées les
élus aux multiples casquettes sont
légion à l'assemblée nationale 80 2 %
des députés exerce un autre mandat et
ils sont 45% à cumuler avec un mandat
exécutif local dans la haute assemblée
la situation est quasi identique
77% des sénateurs détiennent au moins un
autre mandat et 48% d'entre eux ont un
mandat exécutif toujours rose et jack
chose d'encore et au sénat les poids
lourds du cumul son ombre
sénateur maire de lyon de marseille de
dijon et de strasbourg pour ne citer que
les plus connus une exception française
en europe
héritage d'un état jacobin c'est
l'héritage d'une france extrêmement
centralisé
c'est à dire c'est l'héritage d'une
époque où l'on considérait que pour
porter les dossiers locaux et bien il
fallait que le maire de la commune soit
également parlementaires à paris de
façon à avoir l'oreille du ministre de
l'administration centrale et c'est vrai
que dans un système extrêmement
centralisé comme celui que connaissaient
la france le cumul des mandats avait sa
justification
sauf que cette justification elle s'est
largement émoussé avec les premières
lois de décentralisation vieux mais jean
claude gaudin exemples à l'appui estime
qu'il est toujours nécessaire de cumuler
dans l'intérêt des territoires face au
rapporteur du texte
il se souvient d'une époque où il
n'était plus que maire de marseille et
j'ai donc vécu cette période
d'une manière pas très agréable or il
m'est arrivé pour les dossiers
marseillais de demander un rendez vous
au ministre le ministre a accordé le
rendez-vous mais changer de profondes at
puis ont été reçus très courtoisement
très convenablement des de manière
républicaine dit on j'ai pas senti qu'il
y avait des résultats positifs après
tandis que lorsque vous êtes au
parlement de la république que vous
soyez députés où que vous soyez
sénateurs pour nous c'est le sénat
d'abord on est présent au sénat on
côtoie les ministres quotas d'abord les
collaborateurs des ministres ça fait
avancer les choses autrement vous les
connaissez mes repas vous pouvez
questionner un ministre devant la haute
assemblée
et si vous questionnez en plus un peu
brutalement en présence du premier
ministre
eh bien j'avais observé que les dossiers
marché beaucoup plus vite
le sénateur-maire de marseille donne le
bâton pour se faire battre par les anti
cumul qui estime que dans nos assemblées
sièges aux deux barons locaux
mais bon soir car quels intérêts sont
censés représenter les sénateurs se de
leur seul territoire ou ceux de la
nation
très vite le débat se cristallise autour
de la place et du rôle du sénat il faut
bien comprendre que ce n'est pas juste
la question du statut de la situation
personnelle des députés et des sénateurs
qui sont concernés en fait cette loi est
de nature à changer profondément le
fonctionnement du parlement mais aussi
le fonctionnement de nos institutions
et nous disons nous les sénateurs udi
but c'est que on ne peut pas changer une
toute petite partie de nos institutions
si on ne fait pas une réflexion globale
sur toutes nos institutions
les partisans du cumul des mandats
s'appuie sur l'article 24 de la
constitution dans lequel il est inscrit
que le sénat assure la représentation
des collectivités territoriales de la
république
une spécificité défendu bec et ongles
par les sénateurs
on ne peut pas faire du parlementaire un
élu hors sol c'est idiot
le sénat doit représenter les
collectivités locales comment peut-on
imaginer qu'il puisse le faire si on
coupe le cordon ombilical
nous devons défendre le sénat parce que
si le sénat devient la même chose que
l'assemblée nationale un jour se posera
le fait de dire mais on peut supprimer
le sénat et on peut avoir qu'une seule
chambre dans ce pays or le sénat est un
équilibre par rapport à l'assemblée
nationale le sénat et le représentant
des collectivités territoriales pourquoi
empêcher à une mère de vouloir être
sénateur c'est pas possible
mais attention à trop mettre en avant la
représentation des territoires la
compétence législative général du sénat
pourrait être remise en cause
on peut entendre l'argument qui consiste
à dire eh bien voilà le sénat représente
les territoires il est donc une chambre
des territoires
et comme tels doivent y siéger les
représentants ces territoires très bien
mais alors il faut tirer la conséquence
de ce que l'on avance quant à la
composition du sénat
et quand on roule on veut lui voir
attribuer six sénat est une chambre des
territoires sur le modèle du bundesrat
allemand alors ses prérogatives et bien
légitimement devrait être réduite et
cantonner uniquement aux questions
intéressant les collectivités locales
françaises
le bicamérisme tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui serait donc caduc le sénat
et l'assemblée nationale pourrait ne
plus détenir les mêmes compétences
mais c'est un risque que sont prêts à
prendre une majorité de sénateurs
le matin du 18 septembre juste avant la
discussion dans l'hémicycle
la commission des lois rejettent le
texte du gouvernement
mais surprise elle adopte 3 amendement
autorisant les sénateurs à conserver une
fonction exécutive locale
il ya sans doute une majorité au sénat
pour adopter une solution positive qui
partent de l'idée au fond que exercer
ensemble un mandat de maire et un mandat
de parlementaire
ça permet de bonifier dans l'intérêt des
citoyens l'exercice des deux fonctions
si le gouvernement et l'assemblée
nationale s'accroche à une vision plus
dogmatique
nous pensons que le sénat qui représente
les collectivités territoriales de la
république c'est sa légitimité doite à
tout le moins faire en sorte que les
sénateurs puissent être hummer ils sont
des maires parmi les maires des élus
locaux parmi les élus locaux
c'est le cadeau empoisonné de l'ump des
centristes et des radicaux de gauche au
gouvernement
même nos deux chevaliers blancs du
non-cumul affichent leur fatalisme
mon pronostic c'est que le sénat
n'adoptera pas majoritairement le texte
pour ces raisons c'était pas un scoop
tout le monde sait mais c'est assez
logique par rapport à la position de la
majorité notre commission
sous les ors de la salle des conférences
avant l'entrée dans l'hémicycle les
discussions sont courtoises les clivages
gauche-droite bien loin mon ami
socialiste moi je ne sais pas et ben
nous on est des républicains si c'est
voter c'est voter remboursement jackass
urnes forcément je pense que c'est c'est
quand même assez démagogique cette loi
sur le non cumul sur le mandat unique et
en même temps je pense qu'il est utile
de mettre des limites
oui sur le cumul aussi parce qu'il ya
des cumuls ont tous vos blacks sont pas
raisonnables
le vaste que café vacances qu'on est
d'accord là dessus d'ailleurs alain
était un des premiers à démissionner de
ce mandat le maire prévisions justement
tout à fait pas ce qui allait se passer
tout à fait on peut être raisonnable
mais en même temps faut pas être
démagogique le mandat unique absolue ça
me paraît tout à fait d'aimer avec
l'arrivée du ministre de l'intérieur et
du président de la commission des lois
il y a tout de suite salle des
conférences de l'électricité dans l'air
voilà j'ai pris l'eau parce que je batte
manquer mais je me suis sénateur qui se
mouillent
non je suis pas bon pour le non cumul
des mandats de façon à ce que chacun
fasse couiner tâche tu sais il ya
beaucoup de médailles avant tout c'est
pourquoi parce que tu es trop de chance
c'est bien le curve est un peu beaucoup
de talent dans la république tu vois
j'ai un seul mandat
on a eu plusieurs j'en ai eu à vendre a
eu un mail à quai ça fait dix ans nous
engageons dès qu'un la semaine dernière
pendant le week end
j'ai été visité 12 communes où ça enfin
choix de 13 ans se met quand même cap a
donné l'exemple au début de sa carrière
parce que j'ai regardé le nombre de
mandats serait conservée telle est allé
au début tu vois j'ai été françois
débuté j'étais que débuter
l'assemblée nationale
pas forcément le dernier mot
bien sûr il faut savoir animaux si le
sénat participe de ce mouvement le débat
d'aujourd'hui ne va pas servir à grand
chose parce que y compris contre une
majorité les sénateurs gouvernement a
décidé à l'égard de céder à une forme de
populisme qui ferait croire au travers
du mot cumulards
il y aurait une espèce d'abus a exercé
un mandat local exécutif et la fonction
de parlementaire mais on se battra
jusqu'au bout et c'est le sens de ma
présence l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi
interdisant le cumul des fonctions
exécutives locales avec le mandat de
député ou de sénateur
il était très attendu jacques mézard le
tribun du cumul des mandats
plus qu'un bouleversement c'est une
révolution ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est vous monsieur le ministre à la
page 52 du rapport je vous cite je ne
sous estime pas l'ampleur de ce
changement qui est une véritable
révolution est bien une révolution on ne
doit pas la faire à la sauvette par une
procédure accélérée en session
extraordinaire
haché par les congés d'été comme des
braconniers législatif qui font leurs
coûts nuitamment le visage masqué par la
cagoule de la modernisation de la vie
publique
monsieur le ministre pas vous pas ça au
nom de tous ceux qui nous rassemble au
nom de notre histoire et encore
davantage de l'avenir de cette
république que nous voulons forte
rassembleuse respectueuse je vous
demande de rejeter ce texte elle qui
nous les proposer et d'adresser à
l'exécutif le message de la liberté de
la haute assemblée au service de la
république
vive le sénat de la république bis la
république le ton est donné
le débat est lancé et la riposte ne
tarde pas pour d'autres le non cumul et
indispensables à la modernisation de la
vie publique et au renouvellement de la
classe politique
il y à aussi me semble-t-il dans ce
débat une forme de démagogie
parlementaire qui consiste à flatter les
habitudes et à refuser le changement et
le mouvement si nous voulons faire en
sorte que notre assemblée ce sénat se
renforce
puis jouer pleinement son rôle alors il
ne doit pas rester à l'écart les
mouvements plus généraux qui sont
réclamés par nos concitoyens
si nous voulons que la politique soit de
nouveau respecté c'est à dire que notre
démocratie fonctionne alors il faut pas
pas avancé sur le chemin qui nous est
proposé il faudra même monsieur le
ministre allait un peu plus loin c'est
ce à quoi je vous invite ce à quoi
j'invite ce gouvernement et cette
majorité
oui le changement est nécessaire pour le
coup dans ce domaine le changement et je
me
réjouissez maintenant les institutions
aujourd'hui ne correspond plus à ce
qu'est la société française aujourd'hui
voilà moi je trouve qu'elle il ya une la
dimension démocratique et a été gommé et
et moi je trouve regrettable que les
élus se sentent détenteurs de pouvoirs
mais pouvoir qu'ils ne détiennent que
grâce aux citoyennes et aux citoyens aux
électrices et aux électeurs
car quelles que soient leurs arguments
le message des pros cumul passe mal dans
les médias et auprès de l'opinion
publique l'image de la haute assemblée
était corner
les sénateurs vont donc mettre en avant
le non cumul des indemnités
cet amendement a pour objet d'interdire
tout simplement aux parlementaires de
cumuler leur indemnité parlementaire
avec tout autre indemnité découlant
d'une fonction élective et je pense
qu'il devrait y avoir un large consensus
sur cette proposition ça montre la
sincérité la détermination des élus qui
veulent cumulé encore une fonction
locale une fonction parlementaire
véritablement on sait bien que ce n'est
pas pour les indemnités qu'ils font ça
c'est un vrai choix de vie
inflexible les sénateurs vont persister
sur la voie de l'exception sénatoriales
ces amendements prévoient de créer un
régime d'incompatibilité spécifique aux
sénateurs est donc différente de celui
applicable aux députés ce qui serait
inédit depuis 1958
je ne comprends pas cette idée de cette
différenciation vous êtes des
parlementaires vous êtes des
législateurs et votre seul argument
porte sur le fait que le sénateur
devrait avoir un autre mandat qui serait
un mandat local exécutif et ça ne tient
pas debout
et ça n'est pas cohérent par rapport à
la constitution et par rapport à la
cohérence de celle ci je crois que c'est
indispensable d'adopter au minimum cet
amendement
si on veut justifier l'existence du
sénat à côté de l'assemblée nationale je
suis sûr que nous sommes très nombreux
très majoritaires dans cette assemblée
pour penser que ça serait simplement
conformes au rôle spécifique qui est
donnée au sénat que de permettre un
sénateur d'exercer en même temps un
monde en un seul mais un mandat exécutif
local
tard dans la nuit
l'exception sénatoriales est votée par
une large majorité de sénateurs de
droite et de gauche parmi lesquels 25
socialiste une alliance mal vécue par
certains membres de la majorité
ce n'est pas une surprise moi
personnellement j'ai voté contre ces
amendements mais ça n'est pas une
surprise ministre lui-même l'a indiqué
il savait que l'ajout de l'ump lui dit d
r d est ce et de quelques socialistes
feraient un vote qui met un terme en
fait là au sens de la loi tel qu'il l'a
voulu voilà donc ce après juge un roger
enfin une adoption ici mais qui sera qui
sera le contraire de ce que voulait le
ministre nous allons considérer quelles
ces deux c'est une soirée gâchée keane
qui n'aidera pas à montrer à senna
moderne
dommage dommage vraiment mais pour
d'autres bien au contraire c'est une
soirée réussie une leçon donnée à un
gouvernement intransigeant
puisqu'on nous dit que ça sert à rien
qu'on dise ou blanc noir puisque
l'assemblée décidera donc comme on n'a
pas l'habitude de faire potiche
on s'est un petit peu pas amusé mais
manifester et révolté donc ça c'est une
jolie victoire de la révolte
le 19 septembre la loi est adoptée par
208 voix pour et 107 contre une
stratégie habile les sénateurs votent la
loi sur le non-cumul
le sénat a adopté le projet de loi
organique interdisant le cumul de
fonctions mais on sait exonérant du
dispositif un tour de passe-passe
dénoncée par le rapporteur du texte
peut-être que je suis naïf mais
franchement je pensais mes collègues de
la majorité plus en phase avec la
réalité
des bulles et donc c'est quand même pas
tout à fait habituel cueillons vote
contre le gouvernement qu'on représente
mais en même temps ça montre bien la
liberté qui existait il existait aussi
contacter mais ce n'est pas de nature en
a entraîné je ne sais quel déflagration
au final l'assemblée nationale devrait
remanier le texte est supprimée
l'exception sénatoriales
sénateurs et députés logés à la même
enseigne celle du non cumul
une réforme qui ne peut être qu'un point
de départ
évidemment que la réforme du cumul des
mandats ne va pas suffire à elle seule à
rénover la vie publique
notre système qui est profondément
déséquilibré qui est marquée aujourd'hui
par une très grande primauté du
président de la république ne va pas
d'emblée serait équilibré du seul fait
de la réforme du cul
si on veut appliquer le non-cumul pour
les parlementaires alors il faut donner
au parlement qui est un des plus faibles
de rang des prérogatives nouvelles et
aux parlementaires des moyens
supplémentaires renforcer les pouvoirs
des parlementaires mais aussi repenser
le statut de l'ensemble des îles par
exemple revaloriser les indemnités des
maires des petites communes et favoriser
leur retour à la vie professionnelle
après la loi sur le non-cumul la route
est encore longue pour changer le statut
et les pratiques les élus de la
république
on s'était bien passé
le président jacques michau président
sera pour toujours un plaisir qu'à moi
je
mais je me suis rien jusqu'à sénateurs
qui se mouillent je suis pas bon pour le
non cumul des mandats